joe you know
the video that you say that they sent to
ncis and for audience that doesn't know
what ncis is ncis is uh
it's the intelligence organization right
it's it's uh the what does nci stand for
naval criminal investigative service
yeah naval criminal investigation okay
so once it goes there there was one
video that was circulating what was that
one video with the body that was limping
you apologized for that one video i
don't know what they had john was that
on 60 minutes there was somewhere i saw
a video with you
so embody
there's pictures so what they did when
they raided my house they had they took
they took all my phones everything
[Music]
and uh there was a picture
of me posing with a dead isis fighter uh
along with uh 12 other people in my
pretend um
and also i had sent a text message uh
to a buddy of mine
during that deployment as a joke um with
that picture saying good story behind
this got him with a hunting knife uh
that was a
dark humor my but i'll tell you what
that that was the best and pete worst
piece of evidence they had against me um
you know it was the worst because
obviously it makes me look
pretty guilty uh but if you you know
zoom in on the picture and look there's
no blood on the knife there's no blood
on me there's no blood anywhere no no
nothing that shows this guy's been
stabbed uh
but they took that text message and that
picture and that's that was their main
piece of evidence they're like we got
him and that's they were going around
telling everybody they had me dead to
rights like he's guilty
he's going away
uh but they had also since these um
younger guys on my platoon had said
there was a video um
they were you know they were spreading
that rumor as well saying like because
they the judge had put a gag order on
all the evidence so you we weren't
allowed to show the evidence to anybody
and neither was the prosecution or they
they weren't supposed to but as we come
came to find out
they were given whatever evidence they
wanted to the media
to sort of smear my name
but uh eventually we got the judge uh to
uh let us show the video to congress um
because
that lie had gone all the way up to the
white house saying there was a video of
me doing uh this act and so once we were
able to show the actual video
to members of congress and whoever else
it was they quickly realized that they
had been lied to by the navy
and that's where you know their case
started crumbling is that is that pretty
common though when you you know you're
going against an enemy they're trying to
kill you they maybe have killed couple
your buddies people that you love people
that you spend time with you're
emotionally vested in it they're willing
to take your life
you're protecting your country
there's a certain level of animosity and
hatred that's built for your enemy when
you go up against them
is it common at the end to take pictures
of the enemy you take out is that pretty
common that well maybe not necessarily
publicly let me post it on my instagram
but is it common to to do that to say
hey we took this guy out uh yeah but
it's common uh standard operating
procedure uh for some units to take
pictures of the bodies that they've
killed so they can
you know bring back and uh show proof
like especially if they're a high value
target um
and then you know what we we were
messing around uh and that's i would say
that's not common i'd say um
but it does happen uh
you know i think the the environment
that we were in um
it's hard to explain to people just how
it was going into that city every day
there was dead bodies piled up all over
the place
we were watching women and kids get
mowed down on a weekly basis
just watching isis commit these
atrocities so we definitely uh were
super desensitized uh and you know once
you you see that on a regular basis
and you
don't really think twice about messing
around like that
obviously when deployment's over and you
come back to the states uh and
you know certain people like what
happened get a hold of that picture or
see that
they
they freak out and they're like how can
how can you guys do this or how can you
pose like this and it's like well you
know you go ahead and
put yourself in my shoes for six months
and or however many deployments and i'm
not making excuses for it uh you know
i've said it on other interviews before
uh it was a wrong decision to do but it
was done uh you know and i think i paid
my dues for that
yeah and you know
you've seen maybe the netflix series
narcos about pablo escobar
i interviewed steve murphy and javier
pena steve murphy and javier pena with
the two da agents
steve murphy has that legendary picture
that they showed on the cover their
books with
him and a dead pablo escobar on the
rooftop of a
building somewhere medellin
so that's what i mean like is there
there's there's a part of it where
you spend months and months and months
sometimes yours going up against an
enemy where you build up so much
animosity so i guess my question for you
would be the following
what boils your blood like if if if
somebody asks you questions no one
becomes a person at your level
without being
a fighter and having strong emotions
where you're willing to put yourself out
there to essentially bully the bully you
got to have a courage you got to be
brave you got to be a little bit also
you know
uh uh off you can't be not maybe obvious
not the word i'm looking for you got to
be a little bit abnormal like even in
the world of business when you think
about some of these guys that build a
business and they ask bill gates so let
me ask you how much vacation did you do
says for 20 years i never took a day off
that's you're a little bit off if you go
20 years without taking a day off that's
not what normal people would say you're
supposed to get eight hours of sleep
you're supposed to do this no if a man
is on a mission they're not wired the
same way to go up against enemies like
isis but to you what what was boiling
your blood and how did you view
isis and what they were trying to take
away from you or what they were trying
to do to you and your country
you know uh
you know what what boils my blood is
that you you said it uh is bullies right
like ever since i was little even coming
up i've always stood up tried to stand
up for people when i got in a lot of
fights when i was growing up
because of bullies or standing up for
other people
um and that's exactly what isis was as
the ultimate bully i mean they were
they were pulling the most atrocious
stuff i'd seen
in my eight combat deployments and i've
seen you know the taliban and al qaeda
uh do some nasty things but isis seemed
on a whole another level um
and you just don't you don't look at
them after seeing what they do to other
humans
especially you know other iraqis uh you
don't look at them as human anymore
you're just like you're they're evil and
you need to be taken off this earth
there's no
there's no uh
court or thing that they should go to to
you know decide their fate it's like you
chose your fate by being on this
battlefield and by pulling the
atrocities that you're doing we're gonna
kill every one of you so if you like
this sort of short club from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]